Talking to Mister John Andrews, who are was one of the workers
and as it now read without a lot of other things to do then there's life I were where we are born
when stranded North Sydney
and have lived here all my life in the same as Saint Noel in about the third house in the last last serve sixty years
in this house let service greater record is that the recklessly and voice.
It is too long and get on to learn how useful is even our parties
when you go to school at the I did not have much schooling
and unfortunately year I was John of oppression based on we had a go at Manor Queen
and it was only a quick though stated that much about to the North Sydney year public school originally called
Greenwoods, which was comic called after the name of the lovely old fellow was our headmaster
and management became in the name of greenies wintergreen in school and in -year-old Nimrod well yes and Greenwood.
What was he like our lovely for them with great big tall six for God and man who was loved by everyone.
Great great skill and never any trouble of that skill or these teachers.
It was a lovely fellow you never had any trouble earlier with whom you never resent in front of him to take a moving
moment now not in front of him to got a few cure the old train days with studies of the six these days across the hand
of a plan upper because I think I'm a little the fence will slowly my learning what very you like to school any subject
you liked at the hourly subject unlike and could do all withdrawing and I could draw well had a flair for drawing
and the eyes very good at spelling that either spelling bad as four-hour other mathematics
and thinks I was an absolute guard dies never the Blaxland scribble,
so I have alleged girl on the borrow fourteen to go on the creditor was working at the age of fourteen.
The damage was when I was working from those job as a messenger boy in Sydney
and had a good work NL ferryboat before the pressures belt
and that is fun in itself down over the old harbour particular foggy morning
when you get an owl ferryboat practice your one it if you get if you never get there in time a year serving the old big
older brass bells through a trackless skipper has to wary was,
but we made it as a child are what are some things used to get up to around nine Sydney on me.
A week later belittle medically
and we went to remember the handles you might have a bit of a fight with the with the next street gang PS:
putty fights will you go and get some more clay and gather sector within strict that whipped
and needed to bind rocks and had no finish up Roxanne, which is a stupid thing, but there are any inhibitor
but I finished up and I'll are living at the level not fail.
Of course local shopfront again at a lolly water and won't serve well within seven around when you're in jail.
Yes answer with a first cinema her was up in here called McIntyre as it was originally our huge big marquee at bitches
doesn't exist a Satan McIntyre speeches was well known as maxing out to Max
and we get the notice I would say just over pictures on today might happen on the window marquee down where was Max up
in Mount Street,
North Sydney man of another one started up in the on the that which is now Pacific Highway wish blank or lank our road,
and Berry Street_ Waddingtons and the projectionist was Sir R.
I remember awesome me out the explorer and their what yields were we talking about on about nineteen hundred
and the meal worked that out to about nineteen fifteen/ ninety fourteen projection Mosimann is those well really was
all know I never saw saw them then that my mother told me that he was at one time up there earlier, police,
there was another little picture theatre which no one remembers.
I spoke no one living today ever feel right now that the military post office called the Empire picture theatre,
which is a little tin shed and I remember going to my father when I check in hand,
watching the pictures are with terminal via Murano are no know there was in the Orpheum round those days at the first
Orpheum was down opposite where the bridge comes out now in no logical Junction Street,
and that was started by some people by the name of the Governor,
who had a fruit shop up in North Sydney Mount Street and at the first or free and it was originally at ten shared,
but then are rebuilt again in later years to more or less a modern one and you could see the richer are from
when it was a modern one known later on,
when looking down from the roof of the template you know Mal Wellington turned it down because on the same level,
but it said work going on from their super tram didn't go by AMP rocket Jamil.
What error of the First World War, well very little very little in they because our dome ear is warrior oh one
and oh seven nine hundred and fourteen night I didn't.
I can remember this, but the people now in amber sendoffs and we are to go down the waterfront
and just watch the year trip ships go out
and the people waving waving the in a letter to attract their men friend elderly relatives with a big sheet to
something so they could be seen and not a little flag
but something I can remember that another member on the return home in our street.
The couple of the people came back and then there they welcome home signs of put on the houses
and the party that regular motors have a fortunate comeback at a cost of only seven years of age at the time
but taken them well on them in the left over from the party all the kids on the street would be given the left over the
next eight what you remember every year of your father well remember him.
He is he was English laundromat there many year ago. I understand that term was a London police force.
I think it was the black sheep of the family from what they can gallop
and that he finally become basin securely mounted a text on the wall.
The CO2 effects are much so he got to know a very famous old Prime Minister Australia.
I don't know whether you have anything on.
Emma told that term average Billy Hughes and the he call my father Ben and my father called him Billy,
so I think you are selling something going on between up
and I remember that wealth did do the obligatory out of hours no one have no know we got a few little stored my mother
noted, I was in Exeter time I learn each year,
but I think he told mum affair little stories that she could relate to seek to be some little mystery there that he
overheard something and but today is pretty sick about those things are and what would we develop working.
He was working on the walls of the security as security years and your mother body of her Byron
and Motherwell because our lives of the fire–
and if seventy I to the five years I shows Q R I looked after in later life. Yes much electoral.
She was ninety five and very bright, up to the last moment, but for she got ill,
and the she was a country born born famous little township attend alternate town called the gold along,
which is well known
and it's on the back fence on the back of the agenda LeMay challenging your people personally on the back of that
and she still looked wonderful stories of those people who can you relate any of a story.
Yes, I can relate one of them. One of the sad day when I got it under a magnifying classical are small.
I so those Sydney seventh of December physical assemblies pharmacy.
She said I will Mrs them was a mother of this fellow who ran the pharmacy and she'd never ever hear my head.
She is aware knitted cap Mrs M.
and It numbers see the Times bakery here I was,
she said my first boyfriend was in every were the people around the bakery.
She said John Hunter Bessie said just down from the bakery was a bad house
and Mrs Bailey ran a bad house used to bring the built-in from Mudgee and in the morning, using up to the bakery
and get the nice warm breath defeat the clients now must say to you are someone is also she told about gold on L1.
She said after heavy range and have their pick up specs gold in the street of anything.
I am, but the stories you could tell is really wonderful under my grandfather lived there.
He had a small farm at where we had to go out and enjoy yourself.
You know, and when early days we were kids, Ghana, her Christmas holiday from school.
Get a free school pass the hell up and I'll are delightful days,
but a lovely old township new member being the measurement of the things I will their safe
and helped me an alias of our grandmother use create only work on the harvest in the distance away to make this great
big pot of Billy of tea and the these little cakes, sir,
they were called harvest is because of their error like a little biscuit
and they are so Pakula layers wrapped up in uncertainty at what have you only used to walk up to four brothers with me.
He was little older Amelia 's walk up and the take this up to the men for their morning tea
and afternoon tea that comeback alphabet lunch at my uncle 's grandfather things like that because,
however rabbiting with every minor lived at the end shooting and trapping which is a cruel thing
when I realise now that building about her chappie, which is bad. Of course, now Jerry is very now. Now they never use.
First, no matter how they might hear some mine, but I remember going to an old country dance ones,
when my mum was up there with me.
We went out to aware Tattersall sativa well-known name appear not only sets of the never quite realising with the
Tattersalls found above the dances on and that they came from near and far,
about seven o'clock eleven o'clock that night all the members of bed
and mum said we are all the men Don Fisher only gone out the clever rabbit chap.
Secondly to published at the bottom
and then I come round further league with a great big what we used to call those aged four gallon kerosene tins a
square and a tea was made in those are carried out around
and with a big dipper on the end of our may differ out of a jam tin.
The debit output India cup wits and over Melbourne and dance around the hobnail boots and a great old lights
and I can just remember that it was either in each of the time, but I realise now they grow old
and BD stories Henry Lawson. I said what I seem a little bit of it.
Peter was old enough to enjoy it more see more of it right about it when you started.
Do work started as a the new either shatter mission in the city under the usual thing can ownership now than books
little things
and one thing I Mallinder finding a man's face saying things either worked at the age of just about sixteen other
cerebellar take on something John Lamb something I wanted to go into the out of seven drawn one Garth iodine in a
signwriting aiming of the newer fell about it, but I now Ben yarn and I am you don't thank my brother was a form
and are her musical place of earn PLL importers and assemble coming with me and I went on and on.
Learn the year so five years piano tuning and look my best part of it was on the year.
It P&L 's work in which I enjoyed very much because that was so different to love July November they were lovely
instrument wheelie whom fourteen those lovely Steinway pianos which are well framed my love them.
I like working on those term, their nihilism. However, when wrong.
I sent out there and I met some terrific people you know when I had to go out of their homes
and fixed why am I was very pleased to meet either the photograph right down.
I have the date of the famous actors send seeing a named Gladys Moncrieff
and I love her photograph where he signed by her and I remember that morning when I went out to US delightful lady
and she and husband drove me into town that they back to the Hotel Australia after fix of female lovely lady.
She was in the areas that you are with a firm which worked for a year,
including your Ali S is as old I think it from the foremost firms are trying Aeolian Co, a wholly
and they imported the they will be important senior Steinway pianos in Australia
and no of any pretty high grade pianos and play a video back down roles as were or they never made know they've summer,
imported and then have has a firm started here in Sydney called master touch and I am astounded still going
but dream about it that the father is not much demand these days, and the lesson plan.
I was thinking of closing down its virtual museum now there are virtually have the only early roles very vivid.
Any manufacturer lifted us at a site that of the two that about a sum of some government concern
or museum to take over when the numbers are still making them on the other hand are not playing.
I do not know that the real problem but
but these are a funeral had the money which wasn't I spoke to sound a lot these days, but
when I see the price of meat pianos and player pianos, the ours was worth a read.
Call the PMO are the others player pianos that is a difference.
I sounds a bit high for less money, but that we are those open over at stray name penile it was out the first,
the original ones we had one. He admitted his call it an attachment push on it.
We push on WPL and play them on the keys I can like mosaic offenders fingers.
Yes, I was very, very initialling a merry internecine game
and is as resilient guy was them a second dog then close are the depression came planned.
I done everything roundabout the place and you are later offer are laid off less clear, well, things are not bad.
I sell my are with another chappie but then it's folded up the piano you got jobs local jobs found the place
and the bar down a bit of work here and there. Luckily I never had to go on the dole. We were fortunate that way.
I didn't want to have both pride but you get a job doing painting business. Imagine a better gardening.
It kept you outside, which was very good advice on now.
I got a job, then now won't blame with my rugby days chappy can measure the ability of one of your work
and utter I'll get a little medicine are like a job at my work,
so whichever here you'll Asia get your job where he worked and he was a year.
Finance director of this firm, and I don't go to make this relevant on the Friday, which I did
and I was at that phone for thirty three years pump manufacturing game called Bill Barco Australia are about her
opening– either for they do and install eleven thirty three years I retired from them. Our thought on them at all.
I've paid for the house.
I paid for my car and the hours for someone a few dollars a lot you one day and the unpaid editing of
and learned gentleman may break some is everyone getting a job with firm right leg at twenty daily said.
I don't know you better ask him.
He sat there at the club every afternoon at four o'clock out of it will die us MM found that he was firm working for
security for the ANZ bank going round have just going to the banks December report in EMC now everything was with a gun
at the hip which weren't allowed to use
but turgid adjusters Rina Frank tool in case of any bank hold-up in let people know they are being no thought of looked
at Garden nineteen but the new patrolling and that that was very very good indeed we got paid well for our lawyer
and only for use out of our currently second time we got paid well for that
and I enjoyed it very much indeed laughter doing maths that the I was only on their temporary save about twelve months
and the hassle& our many others came back from work and I can been from Emma A 's shadow from the ANZ bank
and said relentlessly and as you been dry for the secured as a yes,
I sent your driver last night were donated with the computer and items.
RG I sent you on my car then they hated were just starting now would you get a worker for several years sure what your
land i.e.
Am got a job with them and I was their first driver with Asian bank for a rare begin up all the computer work
and return it to the depot.
They grill and glowing girl and they put on more drivers until it came ahead of Sydney
and the boss asked me what I carefully go inside.
He said no doubt you get a bit hippodrome,
so I took a job via until the amalgamated with the PSMA bank which is now a sander
and the sewer that is apposite them the job at the well-paid but then, since then I've done nothing in your Maritime
and filament time with my gardening football in an overlap. Now when you left out the bit that I came here for.
Remember less than the Harbour Bridge of home yes, of course.
Of course it first, I don't either deliver the goods must are low.
How can evidently read the depression
and the admissibility virgin about the esky on the region as well now you was examined.
Yes,
that if you were less of course I F Erskine address the thing that is right before I got this job our where I am where
I work the thirtieth exotic Barker at your bacon oyster before I got dealt with.
I thought that that there no eyes and eleven at the good parts.
Anyway, the et cetera me with a foreman painter of the range Fred Calman,
who incidentally is the grandfather of the Mike Gibson me, take them radio and television star
and one you very well immersed as E was a baby.
He was born next door to me and friend asked me today in one job,
you need to get me on so I got a job on the Harbour Bridge work in the firm green gang which enjoyed adverse quieter
exciting are not early, I and I do know that shakes for the first time, but I make sure I had one hand for the BIOS
and one for myself was fumbling up I but in the end I got a real game at as a young and silly argument lemon cilia
and eyes are standard in the dangerous jobs which are others would deal with.
I enjoyed very much indeed at reserve the present great experience for cinema bosses killed on the breeds
and there was that an average Campbell.
He was formerly gamut great believer Liverpool Irishman Liverpudlian I think they called for something
and he was a great trigger a well respected real tough good old bloke
and that he was a marble only went down to do especially jobless down some attempting girders Amber this serve little
tripod that Jewish help Malouf now media drop in cattle for the stuff from our other East rattled down that kicked out.
Then he went right from the top down, hit being light stanchion to the sleepers of the rail lines
and finish up in the middle of the year pile on.
I could go and the shirt off trickle about Janelle come choice about his funeral.
but Today I wouldn't get a record what I saw that they were away a lower was another welcome hereafter notes on a view
that I would like to assure you well as I was not that a further serious
when we went to the church has fed my my next neighbour got a job needs.
He got my brother to drive a car to the service down at Nelson 's point and down eleven Bay and of course all the boys.
They were real goodhearted bloke but rough and ready they went to the service,
but by the time got observes that the main file into a church and wireless and was going on.
I hear someone makes a cry from colonialism less bloody day and that should assure shift,
but she has brought out their main classes was available. They must up the crows nest.
They match up to craziness and down, then. Cars up and down from the cars we went up in the current course.
Well, we went up in court, aged in a whole, the car that were borrowed people are able to get cars
and says they will plough them by the time course I had planned and got on board by the time I got up there
when we got up to the cemetery added before the chairman tournament belt had been buried.
They all need to forget that cars all jumped out how they ran like madly fat what's going on here when I got there,
there was little toilet block.
Well, I suppose, by the timing of their there was enough round for Lumley, so they all went down
and I can certainly outside at that level to Roger you there had no L survey had two well represent our law says
everyone shot birds live in a dish that it stays well the POB sermon started at the grave
and Jim was in the normal way across are they had boarded up across
and all these fellas still half drunk some of them in one fell over a year has some went on,
he went to light a cigarette.
This is true what I'm just now and I, if only good record on camera in later life,
and this telephone the other side to this end, but it end up doing mouth
and the other fella must say to not describe because several deftly out
or at that stage that we sought is asking for a cigarette,
so we take his back cigarettes Jack's older grey biology to the other fella who could come and
or is nearly collapsed they could not believe what could happen well.
Anyway, that rewrite the Melbourne overall abortion via the big shots your bedroom barrel at the funeral course
and I'll just terrible anyway as I put down the car 's amendment Reverend Frank as she picks up a health fame a little
bit of a clay soil. It was not busted Tacitus clay soil. Then he picks other big butt of many puts it on the coffin.
It has been lowered so gems nearest friend and a kind of thing 's name: think his name is Carl anyway,
he thinks well he was intent because inseparable mates.
He picks up a bit of a clay to them in the risk in respect to know he got a bit cautious that had to cough anoint
bulbul well at all these rough are many good time that they are all sincere they thought this is part
and parcel of the main relate all picked up a better clay
and near with as/ four hundred being allowed in with a one-month bank bank closer worse of claim are coming from
everywhere. Similarly, could contest to. I'm not tell hello I I saw it and if I only record it F. C.
Jim is feasible and he would have loved to have seen it because it's a type of for me was that he would have a laugh,
a would of had last hasn't been let down, it was a looked up if they have a glass further top of the coffin.
It laughed and said, let's just what I wanted it.
You remember Pope 's being murdered people only and no, I don't remember when exactly,
but I understand later on that
and the plight are the pipes played the on the way after crazed scientist can't recall the pipes,
but the family were Will it was Sir to deliver you the that either was Sir John Mackay,
who was a stonemason on the on the blast of reaching out on that pylon on the final new there is one of them.
He was one that was laying the final master is about.
I remember one occasion on the beach where a cooler size young and eating beef.
He cannot BT baptised always keen on the condition
and by the analyst also took on roundup in yet another bitter rational.
In my younger days in diameter wrestling and the my Little form nowhere to go round with the year he was threatened,
so it begs me out.
He said the survey nuggets he copied text size enough to get you better walk in with me been chatting with an off the
bridge, so I got the job as my the form of the mind for a while but persisted.
You are known only to gamble no another sub is be your only was an offside at a gym and that if England are in panic
and not, as measured by the yet and is marketed at a walk round with me. I thought it was. I have nothing happening.
I mightily amounted to look after our so I was his mother,
so I been to mind is my life are known to a few of our minor to him attempt vehicle was weaker sale
when everything killed off and owes a minder to the famous Don Bradman,
the cricketer that even those that will have a minute.
Well, I Gemma depression day she played for more cynically, fair
and one of the year players have a friend of mine in one of my rugby mate said a mummy had to do anything.
I suspect some of your body said we got Don Bradman play with us and look,
here's where it is claimed he can never get down to the treaty because he was God naturally never anyone tried a pat on
the back, get their autograph and he could walk to the wicket.
No coming back to I stand by nine I was just the way to have those days, not these data bases aid so only love them.
I had to set by him when he walked down to the year gate.
I let him in and the push of men, women and children out of the way and
when he came off after batting order for feel that it was eighteen escort in up to the official they can neither come
Don Bradman 's minor,
that's only one inflatable cine because he just could not get down to the addressee was together with several
and then firm that same of his game is nice to me and my lung but
but they were never the also says they went over the odds will pat him on the back and I to put another way,
have put another way,
threatening ISOs on Bradman 's minor in the something of the birth you back to the bridge again known to member
Bradfield to be a little too little known the holy land around well where you are they just the men about the place so
stays there.
You walk round welly never came up to the danger spots Thursday that I think it was more
or less earthbound lows this list that he was at the top of my appetite
but are universal much in those days it get around,
but because you would be a senior centre look as a working all the time trying to tough they say hello,
you have to work otherwise get in office posed earlier to make out their work and are no we kept on work and working,
what about term mere he was your boss JVM Roseneath ES Mueller,
will he was the Melbourne long there was a common langues of cider
and he was a fellow I had to interview the next day and when the next day or the day after I had to go
and report to him from different count got me the job traditional John you go down EMC arm to stimulate you'll find him
down our Ptolemy me going down. I went down a look me up and down. He said, what's your name passenger management.
He looked me up and analysed. If I remember rightly had about.
I seem to have a walleye a sunny look Labour Nanny should you look like the bargain.
He said that threaten me yesterday.
I should hope was Acer so apparently now been set them to get jobs now yes Amber so you about rundown
and Liza Marshall wasn't me was ever place is do you look like and
but the only someone look like my M in Alabama that went on those days there appears of your matter how many abusers if
they can get a job